thanks to expressvpn for keeping legal
eagles safe and in the air despite the
dire situation that the world is
experiencing because of the cove it 19
pandemic some people just have to be
jerks like this guy Lars a California
quote influencer who thought it would be
cute to lick a toilet and dub it the
coronavirus challenge he later ended up
in the hospital with corona virus Lara's
inspired people like Ava Louise to lick
a toilet seat herself and this other guy
Cody Lee Pfister filmed himself licking
a row of deodorant at Walmart who's
scared corner buyers don't touch her
mouth Pfister was arrested or this group
of Cincinnati residents who flatted the
governor's social distancing orders by
throwing a coronavirus party the legal
term for these people is idiots and what
do all of these idiots have in common
besides being nominees for the 2020
Darwin Awards they may have done things
that could result in lawsuits or even
jail time hey legal eagles it's time to
think like a lawyer because today we're
gonna talk about a bunch of different
cases where people intentionally or
knowingly expose others to the novel
coronavirus like what happens when
someone pulls a prank and coughs on the
salad bar is it a criminal offence to
give someone kovat 19 and what happens
if you intentionally try to infect
others I'm here to answer all these
questions and scare you away from ever
eating at a restaurant again now let's
start with the basics of assault and
battery most causes of action for
spreading kovat 19 would probably be on
the state level starting with assault
and battery which are both tort claims
and criminal offenses the same conduct
can lead to a personal injury lawsuit
and a criminal prosecution depending on
who initiates the case and the severity
of the actions that we're talking about
here battery is generally defined as a
harmful or offensive contact with
another person's body
now the victims body under this
definition is usually extended to
include things that the victim is
attached to this is called the extended
personality rule this means grabbing
someone's shirt or yanking their
necklace or spitting in their cup can
also be battery even if the perpetrator
never actually touches the victim's body
now purposefully spreading a disease to
another person generally fits within the
deaf
of a harmful or offensive touching it's
certainly not something that people want
in their everyday lives for example in
Pennsylvania a malicious man in a
grocery store was arrested after
deliberately coughing in the face of an
older gentleman wearing a face mask and
gloves because of the potential fatal
risk of cope at 19
this jerk or idiot as we say in the
legal profession allegedly coughed and
mocked the man and told him that he was
now infected with the virus
this guy was also charged with making
terroristic threats as well as battery
and we'll talk about the the Terrorism
charges in just a second now similarly
assault is usually lumped in with
battery but it's technically a separate
offense it's usually the intentional act
that causes another person to fear that
they're about to suffer physical harm if
a person has placed an imminent fear of
bodily harm this is punishable as a
crime or again as a tort as well imagine
you're playing pool with someone in a
bar and that person gets angry and
swings their pool cue at you in in most
places in America if they make contact
it's battery but if they swing and miss
that is assault and you guessed it this
can apply to spreading kovat 19 as well
for example in Maryland a man named
William Eddings was charged with second
degree assault and four counts of
exposure by an individual who has an
infectious disease in violation of state
law after he got in an altercation with
one of his father's tenants screaming
and chasing the man into his vehicle
we're Eddings spit on his arm twice when
police arrived Eddings said he had
tested positive for Koba 19 and then
spat at the officers again not a smart
guy here now under Maryland law assault
is defined as an attempt to make an
offense of contact with another or
intentionally frightening another person
heading saliva actually hit the victims
arm which is definitely a battery and
although his spit didn't make contact
with the officers spitting in their
direction is a clear attempt to scare
them and that was enough for the assault
charge and in this generation where
we're worried about droplets of water in
the air it could be argued that even if
the main spit and it's ridiculous that I
have to go down to this fact situation
but even if the main wad didn't make
contact even the droplets in the air
might qualify as a battery itself and
since assault and battery are also torts
it's conceivable that someone like
Eddings could be sued for assault and
battery in state court and pay civil
damages to the victim
and Marilyn like many other states have
specific statutes that actually deal
with the intentional spreading of
infectious diseases and that's one of
the things that this guy was charged
with but I mentioned terroristic threats
and these days most states have a
criminal offense called terroristic
threats and this offense is probably not
the thing you're thinking of when you
hear the word terrorist it has nothing
to do with foreign governments or
international elements this is generally
a verbal or written threat to commit an
act meant to terrorize another party
when you do that you can get arrested
not surprisingly the threat can be
paired with an actual crime like battery
or murder but it can also be a general
threaten meant to terrorize so for
example if you called up your high
school and made a bomb threat for
instance if there was no specific
statute dealing with bomb threats you'd
probably be charged with making
terroristic threats even if no one was
an actual physical apprehension of
physical contact which would be required
for assault unfortunately there are many
examples of people doing really stupid
and dangerous things during this
pandemic that probably give rise to a
crime of terroristic threats for example
a New Jersey man was arrested for
coughing on a Wegmans employee and
telling the woman that he had the
coronavirus the employee said that she
was concerned that he was standing too
close to the salad bar and she asked him
to move he then coughed on her and
laughed and claimed that he had the
virus he was charged with making a
terroristic threat he was also charged
with obstruction and harassment Texas
teenager posted several videos claiming
that she had the köppen 19 infection and
wanted to kill people with it obviously
the police were concerned and they
tracked her down now this is not without
controversy the terrorism laws were
intended to apply to terroristic acts to
a group of people and generally were not
meant to apply to a single individual
person talking to another person but
generally true threats are not
considered free speech and not protected
by the First Amendment though it's still
controversial as to whether these
statements constitute
a true threat or not so it sort of begs
the question which I'm actually using
the correct way this time but there is
precedent for using state terroristic
threats to prosecute people for exposing
others to infectious diseases
prosecutors charged individuals with
making terroristic threats for exposing
their sexual partners to HIV in the
1990s which led to new statutes
specifically directed towards infectious
diseases according to the Center for HIV
law and policy roughly two-thirds of
states have laws that make it a crime to
knowingly expose others to HIV among
other infectious diseases for example in
April 2012 a 19 year old man who had HIV
was charged with assault and battery
with a deadly weapon among other things
for failing to disclose his HIV status
to multiple sexual partners at least one
of his partners later tested positive
for HIV at least 12 states have added
hepatitis C to the list of diseases that
could cause criminal prosecution if the
infect person knowingly exposes other
people though public health advocates
believe Legislature should be cautious
about passing more laws criminalizing
the spread of disease because it can
also stigmatize testing and treatment
there are probably fewer issues with
adding kovat 19 to the list of diseases
that are covered by these disclosure
laws since Coppa 19 is easier to
transmit than hepatitis C or HIV and
kovat 19 arguably gives prosecutors a
better argument for aggressively
charging people who threatened to expose
others to the virus because of its ease
of communication now the state of mind
here is always important almost all
criminal laws have a mental state
requirement or mens rea a-- or guilty
mind component you can't be criminally
prosecuted just because you accidentally
infected someone you have to
intentionally or knowingly infect them
in situations that give rise to
liability so don't think that anyone who
happens to communicate the disease is
going to be prosecuted under these laws
but where there is really egregious
conduct the prosecutors are probably
gonna bring out the big guns I'm to
bring out the big guy
and one of the most egregious examples
of intentionally exposing people to Cove
at 19 happened when Margaret surco went
to a supermarket and started coughing
and spitting on the food Serco claimed
to have the coronavirus and coughed or
spit on about $35,000 worth of food
which had to be thrown out authorities
don't yet know if surco really had
covered 19 but her actions caused
serious losses to the store in addition
to potentially exposing employees and
shoppers to the virus she was arrested
and charged with two felony counts of
terroristic threats one felony count of
threats to use a biological agent and
one felony count of criminal mischief is
worth noting that it probably doesn't
matter if she actually has the virus or
not for example if you fire an unloaded
gun at someone but you think that gun is
loaded
that still generally qualifies as
attempted murder now Serco being cited
for threatening to spread a biological
agent brings us to whether federal
anti-terrorism laws could apply to Kovan
19 and on March 24th Deputy Attorney
General Jeffrey Rosen sent US attorneys
and federal law enforcement agencies a
memo recommending the people who
purposefully expose or infect others
with Cova 19 should be prosecuted under
federal terrorism statutes now there are
several federal statutes of the DOJ is
considering the first is 18 USC 23 32
which makes it a federal offense to
threaten or attempt to use a weapon of
mass destruction against persons within
the United States and a weapon of mass
destruction is any weapon involving a
biological agent toxin or vector and
biological agents are defined to include
viruses capable of causing death disease
or other biological malfunction in a
human now a defense attorney would
probably argue that the statute was
intended to apply to artificially
created vectors and not the naturally
occurring cold viruses or corona viruses
but the statute is written broadly
enough to apply and despite rumor
mongering to the contrary there is no
evidence that copa 19 was engineered by
china as a biological weapon but the
statute probably still brings it under
its Aegis now Rosen did not mention 18
USC 1365 which penalize --is tampering
with consumer products even though it
arguably applies to people like surco
who go around tampering with consumer
products however this law was used to
the mastermind of the biggest
bioterrorism attack in US history and
could be useful in stopping people from
spreading koban 19 now this example is
so crazy it probably bears mentioning in
the early 1980s Bhagwan Rajneesh also
known as Osho amassed a number of
devoted religious followers in India
moved to the United States took over an
Oregon town fought with a co-founder of
Nike acquired the largest collection of
Rolls Royces in the world violated
immigration laws sedated thousands of
homeless people tried to assassinate
public officials and infected 751 people
with salmonella by contaminating eight
restaurants salad bars the salad bar
poisoning was a plan to stop people from
voting in a local election and if you've
ever seen the Netflix documentary wild
wild country you've no doubt witnessed
Osho's right-hand man ma anand sheila
memorably justifying the cults actions
the Rajneesh she's stole the salmonella
cultures from a seattle lab and sheila
pleaded guilty to conspiring to tamper
with consumer products and wiretapping
federal law makes it a crime to tamper
with food by exposing it to toxic
chemicals or bacteria or viruses as the
rajneeshees did in oregon not
surprisingly and also they're a bunch of
state laws that prohibit tampering with
food products as well remember this girl
who looked a tub of ice cream and then
put it back well she was arrested with
tampering with food products under a
Texas tampering law and this kind of
tampering has been on the federal radar
since February when an FBI briefing
disclosed that white supremacists have
discussed using kovat 19 as a bioweapon
including leaving saliva on door handles
spitting on elevator buttons and using
some of the same tactics as the
rajneeshees now that's a summary of the
sort of criminal acts that you might be
charged with if you go around
intentionally infecting other people
with kovat 19 but what about just
walking around or defying a lockdown
ordered well I have a video all about
the government's legal authority to
isolate and quarantine people during a
health crisis and in that video I talked
about the history of quarantine laws
typhoid mary and the Spanish flu and the
other stuff that happens during a
pandemic and my conclusion was that
lawsuits challenging kovat 19 quarantine
and restrictions on public gatherings
would probably fail because the police
power of the states are really at their
Zenith in situations like this but what
about the liability of people who break
those quarantine and isolation orders
well we've now witnessed state
authorities using their broad powers to
issue orders requiring businesses to
close people to remain at home and sick
patients to be isolated in quarantined
but the unique nature of this crisis has
governors mayors and police making ad
hoc decisions about the quarantine and
apart from the criminal liability and
potential jail time of defying these
orders you might also be on the hook for
damages caused by just people getting
sick from your actions and I think there
are a couple avenues here one is what's
called negligence per se negligence per
se is the laws way of imposing strict
liability on specific circumstances
strict liability is automatic liability
so this means that the defendant is
liable regardless of the defendants
intent or what they knew or what they
should have known if strict liability
applies the defendant has to pay for his
or her conduct if it caused the
plaintiffs injuries and one of the ways
to trigger negligence per se is when you
break the law if you break the law or
there is a statute that says you cannot
conduct these particular actions and you
go and do that the law sometimes says
that you have to pay for the damage that
you caused regardless of whether you
acted negligently or not so for example
in Connecticut a woman was injured after
a dog that was subject to a 14 day
quarantine escaped the woman sued the
local dog warden and on appealed the
court of appeals held that the dog
warden could be sued and immunity did
not apply because the dog catcher
violated the quarantine law and in a
somewhat analogous situation a Minnesota
couple sued a physician they hired to
take care of their daughter who had
scarlet fever the physician allowed the
parents to visit her and take her home
when her disease was at its most
contagious advising them that she wasn't
really contagious the Minnesota Supreme
Court found that the doctor could be
sued for negligence so this is a fluid
situation you can probably expect many
negligence lawsuits against healthcare
facilities cruise ships and other
businesses if the plaintiff can prove
that any of these entities failed to
take precautions or violated some law
that allowed them to be infected and the
same may be true for employees in
high-risk profession
sir locations who were recklessly
exposed the virus by their employers and
if there's one takeaway here and I
probably shouldn't have to tell you this
but I'm going to tell it to you anyway
you shouldn't lick toilet seats you
shouldn't lick food products and you
shouldn't intentionally spread kovat 19
or you might face legal liability
dummies and getting infected with a
virus is terrible whether we're talking
about a person or a computer because
surfing the web unprotected is almost as
dumb which is why I'd recommend
expressvpn for those of you who don't
know a VPN basically creates a secure
tunnel from whatever device you're using
and the Internet
keeping your digital privacy intact and
it's a big issue because every time you
connect to an unencrypted Wi-Fi network
at airports hotels coffee shops
remember all those weren't those great
those were really those were those were
good or even at home you're at risk
expressvpn encrypts your internet
connections using the highest standards
of encryption currently available and
one of the privacy issues in the u.s. is
that ISPs often track and sell your
browsing habits to advertisers and in my
experience expressvpn is also the
fastest VPN by far and one of the best
parts of expressvpn is you can also
reroute your connection to a server in a
country of your choice giving you
unrestricted access to parts of the
Internet and making geo restrictions our
thing in the past
take watching Netflix for example say I
want to watch my favorite British sci-fi
show about a time-traveling alien doctor
I'm a fan but the selection with me
being in the United States isn't like
that if I was in the UK so once I switch
my VPN I can pretty much watch whatever
I want whenever I want or maybe I want
to see what's trending on YouTube in
Belgium or Japan apparently I'm huge in
Japan and they also have 24/7 customer
support which means your questions will
be answered in seconds not hours so if
you want to check it out just head over
to expressvpn dot-com slash legal eagle
right now and find out how you can get
three months free again that's
expressvpn slash legal eagle or just
click on the link in the description
clicking on that link really helps out
this channel so do you agree with my
analysis leave your objections in the
comments and check out this playlist
over here with all of my other analysis
about the legal issues raised by kovat
19 and just click on this playlist and
I'll see you in court